if you're looking to design a website
there are a number of steps you need to
take today we're going to be taking a
look at the second step
which is creating the ui for the website
design
we already did the first step which was
creating a wireframe
and you can check out the video for that
in the description below
but here's a quick preview where we
built out a home page a features page
even a responsive version in this video
we're going to be looking at
creating the ui for these wireframes i
want to design
something which looks a little bit
better is more professional
and it's a closer step towards building
out a
full website design in this stage we're
going to create the prototype ui
for this wireframe it's not going to
involve any colors or images or content
it'll more be a version or a next
iteration of that wireframe where we're
creating it in a design tool like adobe
xd
or in this case figma i'm going to take
you through the whole process of
designing this
and if you haven't heard of me before
i'm adrian from australia
i do videos around design and
development and you can check out my
channel in the description below
but without further ado let's just jump
straight into it
to create our website design we're going
to use a design tool called
figma and this is very similar to sketch
or adobe xd if you've used those in the
past
it allows you to create a mock-up of the
website design on
an artboard which actually exists in
your web browser so you can use this on
windows or mac or anything in general
and you can edit this in real time and
even collaborate with other people
and if you want to sign up it's also
free you don't have to pay
anything we're going to sign up here
with our google account and we're going
to create a new board to start our ui
design
once you've logged in you want to go up
here to
drafts and hit the little plus sign and
this will create a
brand new figma file in this case we're
going to give it a name
so up here where it says untitled we'll
call this
maybe free code camp website
ui and we can start coding this up but
we don't need any code we can just use
design to do this
let's take a look at the different tools
that figma provides for us
at the top here we've got the selector
tool which will be able to move
different shapes and
items we also have a scaling tool
over here we have a frame and the frame
is used to create
new frames or canvases to create our
designs on
over here we've got our shapes so these
are things like squares and circles and
lines and
other objects that we might want to do
such as images and finally here we've
got our custom shapes
text and moving the artboard around
finally over here we've got our comment
section
but we're not gonna really use this this
is more if you have a group of people
and you need to leave
markup and notes for others to review
for your design
let's start off here by selecting the
frame tool
and on the far right here we've got a
number of options we've got designs here
for maybe
phones or tablets or even desktop if
you're doing a design for maybe
something like
a piece of paper you can do that too in
our example we're just going to grab the
desktop size over here to design our
canvas
i'm going to make a small revision to
this however
for the width here i'm going to do this
to 1980 because this is the normal
monitor width that you ex essentially
usually use when you're doing a website
design and the other thing here is the
height
i'm gonna also make this one nine eight
zero and we might also
increase this a little bit as we work
through it but this gives us our first
frame that we can work on and this will
be the home page
so over here you can see a desktop desk
1. we're going to rename this and we're
going to call this home page
and this will be our first canvas we can
work on
now we've got our design that we did
before
on the ipad when we did the wireframe
and what we want to be able to do
is replicate that same design in a
better sort of
mock-up here for this ui design so i'm
going to take you through that but
before we get started let's
open up and have a look at that
wireframe to see what we need to build
out
what's really cool about figma is that
we can literally copy paste content
straight in there from our computers
we can even drag and drop it so here i
have the previous
wireframe we did and i'm going to copy
paste this
just here to the left that we can use as
a reference and
we can see here we build out a home page
a features page a contact page
and a mobile version if you haven't seen
that video i'll link it in the
description below
but what we're going to do is we're just
going to use the home page here as
reference and
i've got a separate svg just for that
which we're going to copy out here to
the right
and using this reference we'll start
building out a ui against this so that
we can create
something which is visually just a
little bit better and more professional
as well
that we can show off to our client as
the second iteration of our design
let's begin by dragging our actual svg
here
into our page and what i want to be able
to do
is create out each one of these sections
but before we do this
normally when you're creating a website
then you're using a
framework for the layout maybe something
like bootstrap with rows and columns
so let's create a little bit of a grid
layout here
there's an option here on the far right
called grid layout
and i'm just going to select one in here
it does a default 10 pixel by 10 pixel
grid
but we want to customize it to be our
own so in this case i'm going to select
columns
and fold columns i'm going to do 12
because that's what
normal bootstrap uses of course the
width for this is a little bit too much
so i'm going to reduce it down
and we're going to select a gutter of 15
pixels
and maybe a width of about 80 or 90 here
just to represent our columns of course
this can change depending on what you're
using but this should just get us
started the next thing we'll want to do
is
create here our section for the slider
image and i'm going to select the box
tool here at the very top
left and we're going to drag and pull
down to the bottom right here a nice big
box this is a little bit too big right
now so i'm going to reduce this down to
maybe 800 pixels
and we're also going to give it a
slightly lighter tint
so here in the far right in the fill
section we're going to change the c4c
for
hex color to just eee and that should be
a lot more visible now
the next thing i want to be able to do
is have a look at creating a menu
and to do this we select this box tool
once more
and we're just going to drag it and
follow our
columns here we might not use all the
columns we might just use
most of them here and we'll give this
maybe a height
of about 60 pixels so let's update this
here on the far right
the next thing we're going to do is
select the box tool but drop it down
and select a circle and for this circle
this will be the logo so i'm just going
to
pull it in here from the top left and
this
might just pop in here as two columns in
width with one column here having a
space between our menu
and our logo and it'll be another circle
in here
so we can see that a lot better let's
take out the
grids here so we can see these items a
little bit
clearly here we go and we can see we've
got our logo and our menu placeholders
there
for our logo i'm going to select the
text tool here
and i'm going to type in logo just
anywhere here on the page
when we zoom in now to maybe say 75
let's just do that here at the top right
and have a look we can pull this
straight here towards our logo and our
circle
and we'll make this a little bit bigger
i'm going to make it 24 pixels maybe
even
48 pixels and i'm just going to put this
right on top of the circle i'm going to
give it a slightly lighter shade so
maybe something like
999 and it'll just go over here we can
add it in later
the other thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to group these two items
right now this is just called an ellipse
and a logo for text
but i'm going to select both of them and
hit ctrl g
and this will now be a group and for
this group i'm going to label it logo
just so that we can be able to use this
later on
if we do we can always expand it out
here on the left or
double click on it to access the items
inside
now for the menu i want to be able to do
the same thing
so what i'm going to do is grab the text
item here
and i'm going to put in a few different
pages
since we know which pages we want to use
it'll be
pretty easy we've got the home page
which we've already built
we'll have an about us page we'll also
have a
features page and maybe we'll have
a contact us page let's
create one more item in here and
normally the
final item we might have is something
like pricing
or maybe purchase and this is usually
on most websites just so that it takes
us to where we need to go
now that we have all the menus done
all we need to do is space them out
equally
because right now they sort of don't
have the correct amount of spacing
there's a few ways we can do this we can
pull one of the items from the very
left here and we can do one two three
four
which is 40 pixels from the left then we
can apply the same
to the boundary so we'll do one two
three four here
but since this is padding from the left
here we'll do another one two three four
so that should be about 80 pixels then
when we do the next unit over here we
should be able to apply the
same amount of padding figma actually
has some tools here that
automatically tell you how much padding
is applied
so here we had 82 so i'm just gonna
reduce that by two pixels for both of
these
and that should be just about right so
if we have a look now it's 80 and 80.
let's move this down as well so it's on
the same line height
and we can then browse over here to the
purchase one
also put in 80 pixels so here is 80
here let's double check that's 80 as
well it doesn't seem to be 80
let's have a look 79
80 80 and this one over here will be 80
as well
then we can move this menu in just a
little bit
so this should be about 80 pixels as
well from the far right
and finally we want to highlight our
active item which is the home page
so i'm going to copy over this box and
i'm just going to create another one on
top here
and this one will have a darker shade so
maybe something like 666
and we're going to invert the color here
for the home
so that'll be white on dark gray
now with that done we have our menu more
or less complete
we can reduce the height a little bit so
instead of 80 we could
push it down to maybe 60. let's actually
move it down
just a tad here we can see that it's
fitting in quite nicely there
the next thing we can do is have a look
at creating our slider here
because right now it doesn't look like
much of a slider so in order to do that
what i'm thinking is maybe
create a couple of those arrows here on
the left and the right
now there's a few different ways we can
do this we could go to font awesome for
example
we go chevron left here and this
is a icon here we can use from font
awesome we can
actually download the svg in here when
we do we can
literally drag and drop it straight into
our design over here
right now it's a little bit too big so
i'm going to resize it down just a tad
maybe down to about say let's see
we'll look in the resizing tool here and
i think for the width i'm going to do
40 pixels and the height can stay at 64.
and that's just about right and we're
just going to center this here
to our slider we'll also give it about
a 40 units there from the left and we'll
also
reduce its color so here on the right
i'm going to give it a 50
opacity just so that it's not fully
black
we could even reduce this down a little
bit more maybe at 33
and that's just enough to give it a bit
of a gray tint but it'll also blend into
the background later if we add an image
in here
we can copy over this same chevron and
place one here to the far right
i'll give this another 40 pixels and
i'll also rotate it so it's pointing to
the right side
and finally we might add a few little
dots here to the bottom of our slider
which might be about 22 pixels in width
and height
and we'll copy them over just so that
they can represent the slides themselves
and which one is the current active one
so let's
do that just over here and we can give
them about
10 pixels of space in between
and with that done i'll also color in
the very
primary one here with that dark gray
tint
so that's our slider done for our home
page it's also our logo
and our menu done and this looks pretty
accurate
comparing with our slider image the only
other thing we could do in here is maybe
some hero text
so in here i'll just put in hero title
and i'm going to give it a slightly
larger font size
maybe like 72 pixels will be just about
right
and maybe a heavier weight at maybe bold
hero title example can be our primary
text here
if we open up the
the frame here with the columns and make
that visible we can make sure it's
aligned properly here to the left
and i'm going to copy this over and make
a smaller
one here and this one i'll give it a
regular weight
and this can be a hero sub
title description
beautiful we'll also give this a
slightly
uh slight opacity at maybe 66 percent
and we can turn off the grids over here
now so we can take a look at that
and in terms of a slider this is pretty
good i'm pretty happy with this hero
banner slider and navigation
we can take a look at creating the next
section in our design here
and the next section if we take a look
at it it's actually doing the about us
section where we've got an image on the
left we've got a title
a description and a button and this
should be pretty easy to do
using our column design so let me pull
this in here to the
right so we can start working on it so
i'm going to copy over this entire
section that we had here for our hero
and create this one with a slightly
lighter tint maybe something like f1 f1
f1
this way we can see that we do have a
height to it
but we're going to work within the
bounds of that height just so that we
don't make
anything too large or too small but it's
consistent with all the other sections
what we want to be able to do
is open up our rows here and for our
rows i want to be able to see them
and i want to work within the bounds of
them and by rows i of course mean
columns but
you get the idea what we're going to do
is we're going to create a
square here to represent the image and
this will span about
4 columns i'm just going to center this
inside this section right over here and
the next thing i'm going to do is
create a description section where i'm
copying out the hero description
and pasting it just here on the right
with maybe a
one column gap i'm going to
bump this height up a little bit so that
it's got less margin between the title
and the description and i'm also going
to copy out this description
create another one here which might be
24 pixels in
width or font size anyway and we're
gonna expand
out this section let's jump in on the
lorem ipsum website here
and let's copy over our favorite bit of
text
we're gonna paste it here in the
description and anyone who wants to
can edit this in the future but it gets
our description up and running
i don't want so much content so i'll
remove some of it
but below here if we take a look we are
almost
getting the design the same here as our
wireframe
what we need though is a button so i'm
going to copy over this image
i'm going to pull it here over to the
right and i'm going to give it a height
of about the same as the menu which was
60.
we're going to reduce the width a little
bit here and we're going to
add some text here to put on top of the
button
here we go and in this case i'm going to
do something like
read more this is pretty standard the
only other thing i might do here
is bump up the text just a little bit to
maybe
28 28 does just about right
let's resize the text sizing box over
here
and let's also center this read more
section
this button here i feel like it'll do a
lot better if it's a darker shade
so i'm going to make it a 666 with the
color for the readme being a white color
and that way you can stand out just a
little bit more
so that way we've got this section done
here and it's starting to look pretty
good
i'm pretty happy with it so far and i
don't think we need anything else it
gets us started for this introduction
section
i only think that the title here for the
hero is a little bit too large because
we've already used this
large size on the hero image so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
bump this down just one lot of units to
maybe
64 pixels or maybe even 48 pixels
48 might be a little bit too low so i'm
going to reduce it down to
say 60 and this one over here maybe to
36.
that way they don't look a little bit
too overwhelming they still fit within
the confines of this section
but they don't overwhelm you similar to
how the hero section is
meant to be a lot larger now let's
take a look at this section without any
grids
implemented i'm gonna re turn them off
over
here and i'm also going to take off this
gray color for the background of this
section and we can see
that it's looking pretty good if we
take a look at our original version here
we can see that we
have quite a bit of padding here from
the top to the bottom that's almost 200
pixels
but we can reduce that in the future
it's more about keeping this section
similar i'm going to copy over this
section but
before i do we should really have a look
at
how we're doing the grouping on the left
here because right now it's a big
mess and we don't know what anything is
so what i'm going to do is grab the
common items in this section by shift
selecting them and i'm going to group
them with ctrl g
and in here i'm going to do about us
section
this will be a clear indication of what
this section is because right now we're
not too sure
in here we can give some more labels as
well so this might be the
image over here for the readme i'm going
to group that as well
and we'll do this as read me button
and then finally we've got one more
rectangle here and we'll call this bg
in case we do want to add a background
later if you're feeling particularly
ambitious you can also reorder these
things so they make sense
logically so for example the title might
go first the description second
the text and the button last with image
here being
first being on the left of these columns
and that's our section done here the
other thing we can do is actually
lock it into place so that way we can't
select it or move it about anymore
this will be a good idea to do as well
here for this
main hero section so i'm going to grab a
lot of these elements here
so that we can group them all together
that way
they can exist as they need to so we'll
call this
hero section the other thing we have to
do is the same here for the menu
so i'm going to group these and call
this menu and we'll pull this
up above our hero section and we could
even pull
it inside the hero section but normally
since we'll be using this
menu outside for other pages it might be
useful just to have it outside
the same goes here for the logo so i'm
going to pull that outside as well
that covers most of our section here for
the hero
and for the about us section so let's
actually lock these into place so we can
begin working on the next section
i'm also going to increase the height of
the home page here
to 250 or 2600 pixels
and this will give us room to create the
section here for the sponsors
so what i'm gonna do is copy our about
us section
and i'm gonna drag it in here below but
i'm gonna make a few changes to it
so over here if we have our button for
readme
i'm going to take that out the one here
for the description i'm gonna also
remove that
we'll only be left with the hero title
and subtitle
i'm also going to put this up all the
way to the top of this section
and i'm going to try and center these so
that they exist
right in the middle of our page if we
move it across we should
have figma essentially tell us by a red
border when it's ready there
finally i'm going to enable our columns
here again so that we can see them
and this image that we have here for our
design we're going to shrink this down
to be essentially
two columns in width and we're going to
copy this across so let's actually copy
this in here
and i'll keep copying this across until
it spans
all of our row here
and these will be our sponsors now you
can see that we've
fit most of them in here and i think
that's pretty good
the only other thing i want to do with
this section is possibly
give it a slight background tin i'm
going to grab the same tint we used here
for our header
but now that we have applied a bit of a
tin we are going to have to expand it
out just a little bit
so that the title section there has the
same sort of height
as it does in the other section so i
think that's about 200 pixels
let's move all of these down and that's
looking a little bit better there
since this isn't a hero title example
this is about
us i'm going to rename all this rename
this to about us example
and about a subtitle
for this section here i'm going to do
this as the sponsors
example and the sponsor's
description let's center this and
since this is a line left in terms of
text there's a tool here that
gets us to a line at center so i'm going
to apply this both
to the title and the subtitle and i'm
going to move them again into the center
so that they're working properly
and that should be just about there
we also want this to have a little bit
less padding
from the bottom there so i'm thinking
just about 200 pixels
and that's just about right but it feels
like it's too
many pixels i'm gonna maybe make it only
a hundred
and that's about a hundred there so
that's
pretty good there for our sponsor
section i'm just gonna move the images
up
just a tiny bit i'm gonna redo how
centered this is so that it just does
look centered so
that's all done and we can move on to
our final section which is actually our
footer so we're almost done for this
design
and it's starting to come out pretty
good let's
remove the columns over here to have a
look at the sponsors section
and the thing about this is that if we
take a look at the about us section
it's got about 200 pixels of padding
there from the bottom and the top
but for this sponsor section it's only
about 100 pixels
and this is because there's less content
so it's got a bit
less room to breathe there simply
because it's not overwhelming with
content the more content you normally
put into a design
the more padding you want to make sure
that you're adding in so that everything
stays consistent
in here i just want to make sure it's
just about 100 pixels so that's looking
good
now for the footer a footer design it
normally has a much darker
tint to it so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to copy over this
home box that we created earlier i'm
going to use this as the baseline for
our footer
over here so let's actually cut and
paste this in here below
i'm also going to make it a little bit
bigger here so i'm going to expand this
out just here to the bottom and that
should get our footer section ready
now if we take a look here in our
wireframe we're using a logo
a contact form and a site map
since we already have a logo here i'm
gonna actually copy this across and
we're gonna paste it here below
we can see that that automatically looks
okay
the next thing i want to do is this
rectangle i'm just going to
group it in its own section here and
i'll call this footerbg
for the time being and the logo i'm just
going to move in here
and we're going to group this whole
thing as footer
for this section i want to open up the
columns here again so we can see what
we're working with
and we want to design something around
these columns so if we
take a look at the actual svg here
that we created before and how it's
designed we can see
that we have the three columns here so
the first one will take up four columns
the next one will take up another four
columns so let's
let's do that over here i'm just going
to block them out so i can see
how much space they're taking up and
there we go
so those are the columns we'll be using
so in here i want to
put my first title so i'm just going to
apply that possibly let's move the logo
here to the left
and let's put in these titles so for the
title here
i might copy over this large text that
we use for our sponsors and just
drag it in below we'll move it up here
into the group
but instead of being a black color i'm
going to make it a
white color just so that we can see it
properly so
here i'm just going to select white and
for the description here i'm going to
set that to white as well
i'm going to pull this in over to the
left so it's aligned left and i'm also
going to give it some padding here from
the top
and this is about 10 pixels worth of
padding and i think
that sorry 100 pixels worth of padding
which i think should be just enough
here i'm gonna write in contact us and
let's just set this to be a line left
and we'll move this back over here to
the left
and here i can write something like send
us a
message i'll also align this to the left
here and we'll make sure that it just
starts off here near the column
so that's looking good the next part
that i want to do
is copying this over and creating a bit
of a
site map so here i'm just going to type
in sitemap
and all our pages
and finally we've got our logo over here
we do also want some
contact information below our logo i'm
just going to copy over this
subtitle text and in here we're going to
put in a phone number
in this case i'm just going to make one
up but that should get
us up and running the only other thing
that we have in here
is actually a little icon there for the
phone
so i'm going to jump into font awesome
to get that
over here i'm just going to type in
phone on their website
and it should pop up with a few icons
here i'm just going to grab the very
first one to download
and i'm going to just drag and drop that
in we'll set the color here to be white
and i'm just going to resize it down
here to
about 36 pixels and we'll just align
that
just to the left of our column here we
can pull in the phone number just a bit
and that looks good we can then copy
this
across and we can do another one here
and the second one might be the email
address
so here i'll type in email at
address.com
and we can fill that in later but we'll
probably want an icon for that too
so over here let's do envelope and i'm
going to
probably select the very first one over
here as well
and i'll just click to download that one
i'll see if i can drag and drop that
in and that has not appeared at all i'm
not sure what happened there
but that's okay we'll just delete this
phone over here
and i'm going to drag it in once more
and i'm going to set the height and
width here to
36 pixels great we'll also change the
color here to be white
and i'll just drag that here next to the
email so we've got the email and the
phone now done
let's do the contact us section now
for this section we'll have some forms
here
so as a form input i'm going to actually
create a
box here and i might give it a white
color
this will represent the input and i'll
just increase the height here to about
60 so it's consistent with the rest of
our buttons and stuff
and i'll also put a placeholder text in
here
for this maybe i'll write something like
full name and we can make this a little
bit smaller
maybe 24 pixels and
we'll also give it a slight shade
so maybe a 50 opacity will apply that
there is our first input i'm going to
copy that across
and create a second one here and for
this second one i'll do
your email
and we'll maybe create one last one here
and this last one we can actually give
it
one more column for the sizing here and
a little bit more height maybe 120 in
this case
and what this can be is our message
so let's pass that in here finally we'll
need a button
people can click on so i'm going to copy
over this input one more time
and this time we'll drag it here in
below
and i'm going to reduce this width here
to two columns
and i'll type this in as maybe submit
now we want this button to stand out a
little bit we don't want it to be the
same as our inputs
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give it a nice dark
color not exactly black but like a dark
gray which is a 333 in the hex colors
and we'll change the font color here to
be white at 100 opacity so that way we
can see it standing out there
so that's our contact form done that
looks pretty good
let's fill out our site map over here
i'm going to copy the
full name text over here and this can be
used for our links
i'm going to set this to a full white
100 opacity color
and in here i'm just going to put in a
couple of
links this doesn't have to be anything
special
just copy out the same links that we had
on our
header here but uh what we can do
is maybe we can play around with the
sizing just a tad
because it does feel like it's a little
bit too small but
once we do i can see that that's looking
much better as we have more pages we
could fill this out and we could even
embed it
indent it if we had sub pages but this
is enough for our footer design here
the only thing we're missing now is a
copyright section
so i'm going to actually create this at
the very bottom here
and i might give it a 100 pixels of
height here
and we'll give it a darker shade so what
i'm thinking here
is maybe the 333 color that we use for
our submit button
and let's copy over maybe our text here
for our subtitle and place this above
the
element and what we want to do is just
put in a generic copyright
message in here so something like
copyright 2020
all rights reserved uh
company name beautiful we couldn't even
put in a copyright icon for that but
for now i'm not going to worry too much
about it it's also a little bit too big
copyrights are usually a lot smaller so
i'm going to reduce this to
24 pixels and i'm also going to
center the text and center the
positioning here so that it's exactly in
the middle of our page
so that looks much better now with our
footer done we're mostly done with our
home page and
this has actually turned out quite good
we can
have a look at all the elements here and
what we can see
is that in terms of the spacing the only
issue i have here is maybe
this about us section is just a little
bit too big
i'd like maybe for there to be about 100
pixels from the top and the bottom
because that 200 is almost
too much so what i'm gonna do is
actually move this section
up a little bit and we'll make sure that
it's a hundred pixels from the top
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
and this square here i'm going to resize
it and just go
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
beautiful and then we can move all the
other elements
up here so that is looking
much better now let's just make sure we
grab all of these and move them
up so if we have a look now we have
consistent spacing between each section
we've got our header and footer
and we just resize our uh our frame here
a little bit just to cut
out the bottom bit here now that we're
finished with the home page let's
take a look at our original wireframe
and how it's been applied to our ui over
here
originally we had our slider image here
and we've applied that with our logo and
our menu here at the top
and that's come across quite well we
added some awesome icons here on the
left and the right
but we've also added in some text here
and this is pretty important because a
lot of the times when companies
do have images they also want to carry
across a statement and this will do that
in terms of the next section here for
about us we've followed the grid
structure here
of column design and we've made sure
that everything is consistent
so that later if you want to do a
responsive design each one of these
columns can break into a row
and for the sponsors section we haven't
added 12 sponsors in there we've just
done six
usually sponsor images are pretty big
and if you
have them really small you won't be able
to see them properly this way by just
having six right here they fit into that
column design a lot more neatly
and if we wanted to we could add more
but they can also collapse down much
easier too
and finally we have our footer over here
where we've had a contact us form
a site map a logo and some contact
information
there's room here for growth as well if
the site expands out further
or at least these are the basics of what
you would expect in a footer as well as
our copy right there at the very bottom
in the next video we might take a look
at color theory and this is more
complicated than some might realize
this is figuring out which colors to use
for this website
maybe we'll have a primary color and a
secondary color and we'll have to figure
out which ones work together and which
ones don't
and we might actually work on some
images too to see
if we can make them work with the colors
we pick but i hope you guys
enjoyed this video my name is adrian and
i do videos around design and
development
so check out my channel hit like hit
subscribe and i'll see you in the next
one
thank you